[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
thank you everybody thank you thank you
uh you can please have a seat i want to
um welcome everyone to this historic
event here at the iron workers hall i
want to thank businessman manager aaron
best i want to thank ray cleland and
everyone here at local 5. i almost said
local 7. local 7's in boston but sorry
i'm sorry
but i want to thank you all and thank
you for hosting us today
as a proud member of labor's local 223
in boston
it's always great to be back into a
union hall uh today joining us is
secretary
jennifer granholm secretary granholm
thank you for being with us today
deputy defense secretary kathleen hicks
thank you for being with us today
we have a couple members of congress and
also local elected officials i want to
thank you for being with us today
and off and of course
the president of the united states of
america president biden and vice
president harris thank you for being
with us
today they are proving once again that
this is the most pro-labor pro-worker
administration in our nation's history
and in a few minutes the president of
the united states is going to sign an
executive order
that order will make sure that big
federally funded construction projects
are governed by project labor agreements
and i know from experience plas
guarantee great projects and good jobs
[Applause]
when i led the building trades in boston
i had the honor of negotiating project
labor agreements for 35 000 workers and
when i was mayor of boston i saw those
project labor agreements bring
opportunity equity and resiliency to our
city
plas are powerful tools they protect
taxpayers investments bringing projects
in on time and on budget they guarantee
high quality results built by the most
highly skilled workers in the country
union workers
[Applause]
and as we have proved in cities across
america
we can use plas to expand access to good
middle-class careers for women and
workers of color
that means a more inclusive economy and
it's a top priority for me as labor
secretary and for this entire
administration
[Applause]
the bottom line quite honestly is
between this executive order and the
bipartisan infrastructure law the
president has provided us all with the
opportunity to create millions of good
paying jobs union jobs and construction
projects built with federal dollars
and this is a historic win for working
people all across this country
now i have the honor
the incredible honor of turning this
podium over to a champion of working
people all across this country
she is fighting every single day for the
rights of workers to be able to join a
union to be paid what they deserve and
get the care and the health care and the
family care that their families need
sisters and brothers please join me in
welcoming the vice president of the
united states of america kamala harris
thank you
have a seat
thank you all
thank you secretary walsh thank you it
is always good
have a seat thank you
it's always good to be in the house of
labor
um i want to thank you all for the work
you do every day that inspires us um and
secretary walsh thank you you are a
great partner
in this effort and a great leader
in our administration so good afternoon
everyone uh before we get started i just
want to say a word about the jobs report
that came out today
uh i do believe i think we all know that
it really shows that americans are
getting back to work
and what we are seeing is that it is
happening at a record-setting pace
as a result of the diligence and the
determination of the american people
and the policies of our administration
our nation's economic recovery
continues to be let there be no doubt
the strongest in the world
[Applause]
and again i want to thank marty walsh
for his introduction and the work you do
every day
so it is good to be back also in prisons
george's county
senator cardin
senator van hollen it's good to be back
with you as always my former colleagues
and of course to be here
at ironworkers local five with all of
you
and i know we're all waiting to hear in
a moment from one of the greatest
friends
of union labor workers president joe
biden so i just have a few comments to
make
all of the work is gathered here now
that our administration will always
stand in solidarity with you and with
organized labor
it comes from our heart it comes from
our soul
we are unequivocal
and clear
about the importance of that
relationship not only to us and our
administration but to our country and
the working men and women of america
because we know
union workers built our nation
you know i i think about a place like
san francisco union workers built the
golden gate bridge
in chicago union workers built the
willis tower
in st louis
union workers built the gateway arch
and in new york city
on hallowed ground
in the years after 9 11
workers from dozens of different unions
built
one world trade center
and so the point there being when our
nation needs something to be built right
and those things that by the way
are recognized throughout the world
as the epitome
of carpentry of building
of of what we do in terms of the skills
that those workers apply
we receive worldwide recognition
so when the united states needs
something to be built right we turn to
union workers
and the reason for that is also clear
union workers are committed workers
productive workers
efficient workers
skilled workers
they are well trained
and well prepared
to get the big jobs done and to do them
right not to mention
on time and on budget
and over the past year i have visited as
i have for many years of my career
union job sites
and worker training centers across our
nation
last month for example i visited a
training facility in milwaukee wisconsin
and there i spoke with job seekers
apprentices
union members
workers who spent hundreds of hours
learning to remove and replace lead
pipes and service lines in a city
that is sadly replete with them
and the officials there they told me
by the time these union workers
finish their training they are the best
in the business
and so that's why one of the reasons why
we are here today
the president and i made a promise that
our administration will do everything we
can
to build a better future for all
that we will build
stronger communities
a more skilled and productive workforce
and a more prosperous nation
as he will soon outline
we take another important step forward
today
to fulfill that promise
and so now it is my honor to welcome
crenita jordan
an apprentice here at ironworkers local
five
and a living example a role model
of what is possible when we invest in
our workers thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you everybody
first i want to say good evening
everybody
my name is krenita jordan and i'm proud
to be a fourth year union apprentice at
local five iron workers
i'm a first generation iron worker in my
family
my mother is a nurse at the university
of maryland capital regional medical
center here in largo maryland
and my father is a union boilermaker
when i started construction my employer
didn't take me seriously because i was a
young woman and stuck me in a truck all
day
luckily an hour worker saw me looking
miserable
and recommended recommended i applied to
this apprenticeship
i did
and before i knew it
i was at the national iron worker prayer
apprenticeship program for women in
california
our labor and management partnership
paid the travel
accommodations food costs and food calls
for all women across the country to help
jumpstart our career in the trades
after three years of intensive training
i came home and started my apprentice my
apprenticeship in local five
construction is a career
that allows you to self-express
you don't have to hold back your
personality
and i love the honest respectful
relationship i have with my crew
i also love the feeling of the
achievements
i can walk to the new term of ronald
reagan national airport and said i built
it
i can point to the shimmer and glass
windows at dc wharf and said i'll put
those in
[Applause]
private sector developers and
contractors use project labor agreements
because they want their projects built
right by skilled workers and apprentices
just like me
that's the goal of the
executive order that the president will
sign here today
to make sure the federal
construction projects are completed
safely on time and under budget
i know companies like google microsoft
toyota and other use plas for their
construction projects and now the
federal government government will do
the same
project labor agreement also gives
labor growth also have a great record
for diversity
helping bring in people like me who've
been historically pushed out from the
construction industry
this order will help all countries build
back build back better with
opportunities for all americans of every
race and gender
[Applause]
i can't wait to graduate for my
apprenticeship this summer
and to get the work on the big projects
covered by this executive order
but first it's my honor to introduce the
man who's going to sign it
he's a lifelong friend of workers like
me who believe our best days are still
ahead of us he signed a bipartisan
infrastructure law to help to make this
happen
he wants to see women and minorities
working on the front lines of these
projects and
and not stuck in the action of that
stuff that's watching the actions from
inside the truck
with that is my privilege to introduce
you president joe biden
[Applause]
that's progress
you know folks thank you
thank you
before i begin my somewhat formal
remarks
walking in here today and seeing you
guys sitting on that beam
first local ever to endorse me there's a
guy named tommy shrank
in ellsmere delaware
local iron workers
last week came out to a site
they took me up on an elevator outside
there's forum crazy sons of guns like
you all sitting having a lunch on a bean
i guess about 12 stories above the
ground
you're nuts
thank god you are
i'll tell you what
you've got to not only have some brains
you've got to be coordinated to be an
eyeworker man
and i was told
that i said you know they've
done a cut out of
of number 46 the vice president
presidency
i'm the 46th president
and i'm thinking maybe i can take it
home
that's solid steel man
and you guys did that on your time well
thank you very much i'm not gonna try to
take it home
look folks it really is uh it's an honor
to be here for real
and i want to thank uh
your soon-to-be
new full-blown full
poor iron worker
i marty's already trying to get her to
boston but that's another thing i got to
warn you about
but folks look
it's an honor to be here with vice
president harris
and with labor secretary marty walsh a
proud member and former president of
labor's local union
222 223 up in boston
and our secretary of energy jennifer
granholm got a few things we're going to
build
and uh and and i want to thank the
maryland delegation
ben cardin who's been a friend for a
long time and chris van hollen who's a
really close friend an outstanding
congressman anthony brown and other
elected officials are here look
all
of whom fight for working people
in maryland and every and every other
state because what happens here it
happens around the world happens around
the country
it's been an honor to be with the iron
workers of local five and we talk about
we talk about building a future that's
made in america we're talking about you
this time we're going to get it really
correct
you know one of the press persons said
to me and i can't remember who about uh
three months ago
that i don't know that's factual or not
but he said you've used the word union
as president more than any other
president in american history
so let me tell you
let me tell you
i'm not sure that's true
but i tell you what
i promised you you'd have a union
president
and i am because you're the best now we
talk about
whether you know wall street build
america they're good folks on wall
street they're not not bad folks they're
good people all over the country
i'll tell you who built america the
middle class
and the people who built the middle
class are organized labor unions unions
unions did that's not hyperbole
that's a fact
that's a straight fact
the executive order i'm going to sign
today
is going to help ensure that we build a
better america we build it right and we
build it on time we build it cheaper
than it would have been otherwise
you know the executive order is making
sure that federal construction projects
get completed on time and under budget
saving taxpayers money clearing
construction zones quickly and ensuring
that everything the federal government
signs to contract to build is built to
last
you guys really genuinely are the best
in the world not that's not hyperbole
it's a fact
to do to do that we're using a tool that
iron workers here know very well
called project labor agreements i know
you all know but folks who may be
watching this may not fully understand
it
simply put these agreements
that contractors subcontractors and
unions put in place before a
construction site gets underway before
the construction begins
they ensure that major projects are
handled
by well-trained well-prepared highly
skilled
workers and they ward off problems
they resolve disputes ahead of time
ensuring safer work sites
avoiding disruptions and work stoppages
that can cause expensive delays down the
line
and that makes a big difference for the
american taxpayer
because when big construction projects
are completed efficiently
with the highest degree of
professionalism
is good for the american taxpayer that's
not hyperbole that's a fact
we don't talk about it those we don't
talk about how you all save
the american taxpayers money
it's good for families
who live in those communities all across
the country with federal construction
projects are being built as i speak
and it means that modernization of your
local waterways will get done sooner
won't cost twice as much as expected
and when the next storm comes the power
will more likely stay on and homes and
business will be better protected from
flooding
it means new air traffic control towers
at the local airports will be up and
running more quickly
so flights are safer at the airports
more efficient
means new housing we build on our
military bases
will be of the highest quality which
these service members deserve
and we'll hold up better and make life
easier for our military families
the executive order i'm going to sign
will help defuse problems before they
arise
they're going to improve coordination
between contractors subcontracting
workers on the job site
it's going to help guarantee a
consistent supply of high quality highly
trained workers
you know what people don't understand if
they're not don't know the industry
you know it's like you going to college
kid four years
four years of busting your neck learning
a trade
this isn't something you walk up and
show up in the day and raise your hand i
need a job
you work like the devil for it
fortunately you get paid while you're
doing it you're able to do it
but it is an education
full-blown education you're getting in
your trade
well you have a voice
in the work site
full commitment to getting the job done
it's going to raise the bar on quality
for some of those vital projects we're
going to be building
we're going to make sure that federal
construction projects are staffed with
good paying union jobs
[Applause]
one of you actually came up to me today
and said joe you said you're going to do
that you're doing it
well
when president obama asked me to
run the recovery act
i made sure every single job i could get
was a union job prevailing wage
because i've noticed
when folks are getting paid a decent
wage
everybody in the community does better
everything looks better
the jobs you can raise a family on
whereas my dad would say
their jobs you can put your head in the
pillow at night and just have a little
breathing room
a little secured a little breathing room
jobs that can't be outsourced
that's good for nearly two hundred
thousand workers on federal on federal
construction contracts
right now
it's good for everybody
i don't want to get going because i
don't keep you here too long because you
know all i'm about to have what i've
said and you know what i've done and you
know what we're doing and you know i
know what you're doing let me close with
this
a week ago i went to pittsburgh
to tour a former steel mill
it's now a cutting edge manufacturing
research and development hub
right before i left to the trip
i got word that a bridge collapsed you
saw it on television
it looked as bad in person as it did
at the time the bridge had been rated in
poor condition like i might add over 3
000 bridges in pennsylvania 45 000
across the nation
we've been rated that way for the last
10 years
when i got there
folks told me something close to a
miracle had occurred
because of a snowstorm that morning
school openings were late
and
commutes were delayed
so when that bridge collapsed and it was
well over 100 feet off the two almost i
i don't i didn't not know the exact but
probably from down to the creek where
that went over and the ravine
probably a couple hundred feet
when it collapsed
instead of a bus with a couple people
out being packed with school buses full
of children
the people on their way to work and the
bridge
that is one of the busiest bridges you
know there are more bridges
in pittsburgh than any other city in the
world of the three rivers
the bridge was empty relatively empty
fortunately no one was killed
but for a snow storm
just the mountains imagine the
challenges we face and the opportunities
to build a better america
and extend far beyond roads and bridges
now that we can know we have to do
we pass that infrastructure bill
but it's not just that
across the country right now there are
countless buildings ports airports power
stations and other federal construction
projects
that need to be modernized
and built for the future
we can't count on miracles like happened
out in pittsburgh
prevent tragedies they're waiting in
plain sight
but we can count on
what america's always counted on
the american worker
the hardest working best trained workers
in the world
american workers who've given just half
a chance
have never ever ever ever ever left
their country down and gotten the job
done
that's what this day is all about my
view
getting the job done for the american
taxpayers
getting the job done right first time
you know folks
there's a law
that's existed for a long time there's
too many exceptions like this one had
and that is that
by america as president united states i
award contracts
and i'm now making it the case and we're
just working it's one of the reasons
those jobs are up
is unless
the product i'm purchasing for the
american people
was made in america
and all of its component parts were made
in america we ain't buying it
we're just simply not buying it and
what's going to happen here
not a joke
it's a fact it's not a violation of any
international laws either
what we're talking about here
with three exceptions i won't bore you
with and they're highly unusual with
three exceptions
every single project
we're talking about
that's paid for with federal dollars and
it's a federal project
it's going to be a union jobs
every single one of them
last time we tried it with so many
exceptions i think only 19 20 jobs
there could be thousands
thousands of people put to work
not a joke i mean this is serious
and guess what
the american public is going to be safer
and it's going to be cheaper
cheaper paying the right wage and the
right trained people to begin with
get the job done
right and on time
so i'm about to walk over
and signing executive orders gonna make
that happen
and we're gonna start with that order
assigned
just remember
it ain't labor it's
unions
thank you
i usually have a pen to give out to
everybody around you but we didn't have
enough pens to bring with us
so i'm going to sign this order but
you're all going to get one of the
signing pens starting with the maryland
delegation
there you go
[Applause]
thank you all
thank you thank you thank you
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
be
um
[Music]
down
you